[Music]
let's go to sarah in
canoxville in knoxville tennessee what's
up sarah
hey how are you dr john good hey do you
have um
eyebrow gel
i do yeah
dude i'm learning so much this is
fantastic
i feel like everything in my life is
different i should listen to this
podcast and learn more things okay so
what's up how are you
i'm good i i just have a question about
my sneaky snakey 12 year old
uh i have three
you have the only sneaky 12 year old in
the whole world i know i know so this is
going to be you know a really difficult
question but um she's our oldest
she is 12 she is um just sneaking
everything
so my question is
do i need to be searching her room and
by everything i mean
she found an old ipad and was using it
to get on the internet unsupervised she
takes my clothes she takes my makeup
including my eyebrow gel so
i'm gonna i'm gonna put a hard no on
that one you gotta draw the line
somewhere sarah and that's it right
boundaries
um
so i'll answer your question we'll get
to it
where where does she learn sneaky
you know my husband and i say she was
born sneaky she was sneaky as a toddler
um
i i am not sure you know i try to be
very open about talking about
these are our expectations these are our
boundaries
um
and so i don't know if it's just being a
12 year old now that she's
being sneakier
or if she just doesn't feel comfortable
talking to us about stuff and and would
rather sneak around
so yeah so what
this is a whole other conversation we
could have at another time you're in
knoxville come down and we'll get coffee
here in the in the studios and we can
chitchat
um
whenever somebody's got a really sneaky
kid
i always want to step back and look at
are there conversations in the house
like hey don't tell your mom
or we're gonna go get sonic drink do not
tell your dad and we kind of laugh and
play
is there somehow is this leeching its
way through the rocks and making it to
the uh aquifer down below inside of her
maybe not
but i always want to look at where am i
quote unquote being sneaky anytime
somebody walks in the room do i
um turn my phone off real fast or are we
watching things on tv and then she walks
in all sudden we hit me are we creating
a world where she wants to know what's
going on behind that curtain right
um
so
that that's one one thing the second
thing you touched on and i think it's
really important is is there a world
that she inhabits where she is told
these are my boundaries versus here's
the way our family is
um this is the way like you better do
this let me say it this way
often kids who feel like they are
responsible for the emotional regulation
of the adults in their lives create
inner worlds that nobody else has access
to
and then adults call that sneaky does
that make sense
yeah i think so it may not be your house
that may not be your world that may be a
teacher that may be a coach it may may
not be any of that stuff right it could
have like you said just she got shot out
of the cannon that way i always want to
look at what is it about this ecosystem
that my
son or daughter doesn't feel safe
talking to me about like what what is
why would they need to go down that
rabbit hole and hide or whatever so that
leads us to
um
your your question and this is gonna be
a controversial answer and i don't care
um
they do not have a room they are 12.
yeah okay
particularly when it comes to
electronics
search every electronic let them know
you're searching every electronic and
hold them accountable as this is who we
are as our family when it comes to
electronics
that might mean that you are going to
change what movies you watch that might
mean you're going to change some of the
music you play because this is who we
all are
and but we are definitely going to get
involved in those things what i don't
like kids doing is imagining that
they have some sort of inner sanctum
inside their parents home that no one
else has access to
uh that's how you end up in some major
issues where parents are like i had no
idea they were building a bomb i had no
idea they had this or that or they had
drugs and
and i always want to say it's like
literally 25 feet from your bedroom how
did you not go in there it's like well
that was their space like no dude
they're 12 they're 10. there's a reason
it's against the law for them
they can't get their own home right
because they're kids
and this is a very modern phenomenon
i also know there's a ton of pressure so
tell me if you just said hey i'm gonna
start checking your room or she caught
you going through her stuff
what would that even like would that
cause a fight
no i don't think so because i i've told
her you know hey i found this in your
room i think i'm probably gonna start
checking your room and not telling you
you know and and she just kind of said
oh okay you know it really i was
expecting more of a reaction out of her
but she didn't so i'm almost wondering
if she
feels safer with me checking in on that
um there's some of that probably um i
don't want it to
room checks are about
let me see it this way there's not like
a um like they're gonna stand outside
like in a in a salute position and
you're gonna go through the room like
with the white glow that's not we're
talking about it's more of i'm gonna be
in and out of your room all of the time
you're gonna help me change your sheets
you are i'm gonna check and make sure
your room's picked up
um once every couple of weeks we're
gonna go through and make sure your
drawers make sure your socks are all
folded up right it's not a matter of i'm
gonna go in because i don't trust you
you don't wanna do that you don't wanna
to set up a culture where you are
untrustworthy so i'm gonna go through
all of your things
there is a culture i'm in and out of
your room it's not weird right it's it's
it's actually weird in my house when my
son's like dude you haven't come in my
room in a few days
because
um i'm in and out of there all the time
and so when i'm in and out of their
autumn i can point and say dude pick
that up gross or clean out your snake
cage or whatever the thing is does that
make sense
yeah and he knows i'm gonna be helping
him change his sheets which means as a
dad i've gotta get off the couch and
actually help him change his sheets
but he also knows if he hides stuff
under the bed i'm gonna find it yeah you
see what i'm saying
yeah absolutely so it's more of a
cultural shift inside of a home it's
less of a
what i don't want people to do is hear
this and hang up and then go okay cool
like raid time like that's man that
you're going to create a great division
between you and your child it's more
about i want to be more and more a part
of your world um have you taken her out
and just started like a routine
mom and daughter breakfast have y'all
started that
no we haven't i would recommend that uh
more about house middle school and if
you can start being honest with her
about some of the crap you had to deal
with in middle school
there'll be some connectivity there and
what we're doing there is building a
well of
that old lady that lives in this house
she's trustworthy i can trust her you
know what i mean
yeah and then you can get to the deeper
conversations of like tell me about tick
tock what's so great about it like why
is this cool why is it not cool right
and then you can really get into some of
those conversations that they can only
have when they feel safe but thank you
for loving your daughter enough
oh yeah she's great
she's wonderful she's so smart and
athletic and like she's she's just the
best yeah that's so cool she's lucky to
have you um and you touched on something
i think it's important before we before
i get off the phone here um
12 year olds are super curious and i
don't ever get upset with curiosity i
love it i think it's great
if i have pro have provided access to
things in my home
usually via the internet because
of um
because i lack boundaries or i wasn't
paying attention i don't ever blame a 12
year old for their curiosity i blame
myself for not creating boundaries that
are going to keep my kids safe
the same as i don't get upset with it
well i would definitely get upset but
if a 12 year old has access to a loaded
weapon that's on the adult in the room
not the 12 year old right and we can
make all the rules like 12 year olds you
don't do this and great the adults have
to step up there right so um
yeah i think they're going to be curious
it's going to be both and when when
there's a behavior with a kid always
remember this i've said this a bunch
i'll keep saying it behavior is a
language behavior is a language what are
they telling you the kid's sneaky
they're telling you
i have to have a safe inner world
because my outer world isn't safe and
let's work on that that level of safety
somehow somewhere
and she's lucky to have you sarah